All right, we're continuing to hear from people
via discord at David Pakman dotcom slash discord.
Let's go next to why don't we go?
Oh, I don't know.
There's just so many interesting locations.
Let's go to Sean from San Antonio, Texas,
next.
OK, yes, I can.
A David just got into here about a year ago,
but I did have a question is that I just yesterday
I have a roommate here that we're both on
kind of different political ends of the spectrum.
OK, and starting to go and kind of get some,
like, whispers of different, you know, father.
Right.
Kind of cute stuff.
And I kind of had to go and actually sit down
with her and kind of have like a discussion
of like, hey, like so what's going on?
And try to meet in the middle, if that makes
sense.
I don't know how you meet in the middle with
cute stuff, but it sounds like you're kind
of trying to stage an intervention of sorts,
which is good.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm just trying to understand it more.
And I kind of ran into as the circumstance
yesterday was kind of the situation where
I was kind of wanting to at least have the
conversation because it kind of got to the
point of she was so emotional that she was
like crying, kind of like, why is this happening?
And kind of having, like, anger and disgust
of what's happening in the country.
And but wait a second.
We need to clarify that, because if you're
talking about a coup, was she crying because
they stole it from Trump or was she crying
because there were violent riots incited by
Trump?
Oh, well, I mean, the specific thing that
she brought up was that the media is going
and saying that antifa are.
Oh, no, wait, what is that?
Antifa was the one that actually went and
stormed the Capitol.
And I kind of just let that one go because
I'm not going to I'm having to live with this
person.
Yeah, completely delusional.
But you can't do anything about it.
Yeah.
And so but but with that circumstance, the
situation I ran into was that they wouldn't
want to engage.
And I understand that we're not going to be
able to kind of meet in the middle as we were
talking.
But yeah.
What would you say in going and deprogramming
the the conversation to get people to start
understanding that, like, you know, this is
what happens in life?
Like I had to go and live with a kind of crazy
for years, the last four years, and you didn't
have your side win.
And that's kind of what it is.
And we kind of need to make it past that.
But I guess suggestions, unfortunately, the
que stuff, some of these people are so far
gone that I mean, listen, I think back to
the Jim Jones cult.
Were you going to be able to just pull someone
aside and say, hey, you know, this is pretty
wacky, you should quit?
Obviously, that's not going to work.
There's a level of radicalization and and
a true belief as they see it.
I don't know what I really do not know when
someone is in that deep, I feel like you almost
have to say this person is lost and maybe
we'll get lucky and something will happen
by chance to change their mind.
But let's focus on fixing education, culture
and media literacy to prevent someone from
even being susceptible to this in the first
place.
Because I don't know how you do radicalize
someone that someone like your roommate, I
don't know.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, it's definitely a work in progress or
at least trying to go and keep some civility.
Yeah.
With that in the switch to change, is that
what would you have is guidance towards going
in and kind of enacting are being more a part
of that change, if that makes sense, because
I'm now with kind of everything that's been
going on, been getting more kind of into it,
but still kind of, I guess, looking for the
next right steps to go and start pushing towards
agendas that are a little more in the positive
for people.
There's no shortage of ways to get involved.
If you want to get involved with education.
I mean, it depends how local you want to go.
But I mean, there's so many ways to affect
positive change in our communities, get involved
in local races when there's a candidate that
you believe in and that you think is going
to make the changes that you want to see.
If you think that part of the problem we have
is the electoral vote, get involved in pushing
the national popular vote interstate compact.
If you want to focus on getting no longer
filling up prisons with nonviolent drug offenders,
you can get involved with drug policy.
I mean, there's you have to there's so much
you just have to figure out first where you
can't focus on everything, figure out what
what is most important to you, and then figure
out how to get involved in that specifically.
Got it.
Well, I appreciate it, David.
You have a great attitude.
My pleasure.
You as well.
Great.
That so many people want to get involved.
That's that's that's the start for sure.
Let's go next to Fran from Philly.
Fran from Philly.
You're on the air.
Look.
Yes.
You're on the air.
OK, yeah.
I'm beginning to show a question for a few
months now up until.
OK, so, my friend, in order for me to hear
you, you're going to have to figure out if
there's a piece of paper or a banana or a
shirt sleeve rubbing up against your microphone
or what it is, because every time you talk
it, we just can't hear you.
But can you hear me now?
Yeah, that's much better.
OK.
OK, so I just wanted to get I just wanted
to get into this thing I saw on Twitter.
OK, so this guy named Eric Hernandez, he has
he has a long Twitter thread going on and
he's basically saying that members of Congress
are colluding.
No, he's basically saying that members of
Congress colluded with the terrorists.
For example, Ayanna Pressley said to her panic
buttons were removed, four were removed from
her office.
And Clyburn also that his unmarked office
was looted right marked office remain untouched.
Right.
So let me explain that second thing so people
know.
Congressman Clyburn says he believes that
there was some inside job aspect to what took
place because he has two offices.
He has his office, that is his office as a
congressman with his name on it.
And then he has an unmarked office where I
believe he's the majority whip, where he works
as majority whip and that only insiders would
know about the unmarked office and the location.
Otherwise they would just go to the one with
his name on it.
I've seen that.
I don't know the truth of it.
I want to be clear that a lot of this stuff
is being asserted.
And if these things are true, there have to
be answers.
I don't know.
And I want to be careful about asserting things
that I don't yet know more about.
But you're right, these these allegations
are being made.
So how do we move on from this?
If these things would have been true, how
do we come together with Republicans?
I mean, listen, I hate to say this, but I
don't know that there is any coming together
with the current Republicans, I it's it's
terrible just to have to say it that way.
But how is this Republican Party that either
is Trump or stood aside while Trump destroyed
the country because they decided it was best
for them?
How do you work with them?
I don't I don't know.
I don't know that it's possible.
Sadly, I wish I had something more optimistic
to say.
Thank you so much.
My pleasure, Fran.
It's a depressing call, but an important call,
certainly.